I'm assuming that a lot of American
alcohol is gonna be sugary like the
food's bigger brighter more colorful
monkey Mickey Bud Light Lime Oh my
sister up it's really sweet that hit the
spot
it's like the kind of beer that I like
which is beer that doesn't actually
taste like beer I would drink it again
and I'm going to do that right now
well very good color scheme here very
patriotic for the American state that is
watery as far likes a little punch I
don't taste anything at all I like that
a lot
this is like 4x I think its iconic yet
it's [ __ ] count draft if you watered it
down it looks stronger on first glance
which is this looks kind of like a
hipster beer oh that does taste fancy
good good this is normal B and this is
how they should be I love it
oh no no no it's not watering so you can
good job America this is good this
should be your number one beer
not bad life that's a [ __ ] chode of a
can like a bogan sighs ohh
natural what does that mean so like a
natural fountain of beer flowing if so
where is it it tastes a bit like armpit
II take [ __ ] water beer is there beer in
this Mike's Hard Lemonade this looks
like that like a Smirnoff or something
like a lemon [ __ ] 5% alcohol is for
[ __ ] feel like I'm 16 again not that
you can drink it six days in Australia
not that I did that this is kind of piss
wake I've taken up hot it's my fleming
night your king lion Mike
[Music]
so bigger that's what she says this is
King illegal this was banned for a
really long time cuz it's I had caffeine
in it holy [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god what the
[ __ ] in Australia we've had something
like this called elevate which got
banned I need to recreate the original
fall okay well a hard no I'm not gonna
try that again there's a lot of
government warnings on this bottle oh my
god oh [ __ ] oh we got some yogurt or
something my mouth's on fire
[Music]
bring it on I'll have another shot
striving on shot
[Music]
I think American alcohol is sugary and
watered-down it's no better or worse
than Australian alcohol American
alcohols fun right now I love American
alcohol I think you guys do a very good
job that was like a spicy after I was
gonna say afterbirth
it's a spicy afterbirth ah I'm not drunk
why would I be drunk you just brought me
in here in the middle of the day to try
alcohol spicy afterbirth spicy
aftertaste
you